hi welcome to science manga from science
mission and so that you applied we have
today dr. mark using Christian professor
in the Department of Neurobiology
physiology and behavior and physiology
and membrane biology with us is from
University of California at Davis
dr. fusing has won several awards
including Dutch zoology award in 2006
from Royal Dutch geological society
endocrine shock scholars award in 2007
from the endocrine society no one odd is
evolved for endocrinology in 2011 career
development our in 2013 from Juvenile
Diabetes Research Foundation and say
Helmsley award in 2015 from The
Endocrine Society and and Schley
Charitable Trusts individual biomedical
research award in 2015 and he was
nominated for the el martes Young
Investigator - it is evolved in 2016 in
addition that we are using is a member
of several societies and has published
several articles in well-known journal
welcome to producing virtually thank you
for joining the science angle thank you
forever pressure and let's talk about a
little bit about your background
researching the education at all and all
the thing sir so um I currently work at
UC Davis as she said and I did all my
formal education in Netherlands both my
Masters of Science in biology and aging
I did my PhD at the University of Miami
and on a different topic than when I'm
working on today I used to work on the
evolution of immune and endocrine
systems and I've been working on and
soluble signals hormones cytokines
pretty much for my attack later so
that's kind of the red thread that ties
it all together and that
my undergraduate career I spent some
time in the u.s. in Portland and like
that experience and got an opportunity
to go back to the US after my PhD I was
invited by white veil to join this lab
and it's at the Salk Institute so um and
when you get an invitation to go work
and live in San Diego it's hard to say
no so we jumped on the plate behind that
and went for a postdoc at the Salk
Institute and and lay there for almost
10 years and then from the Salk I moved
on to my current position educators okay
so can you talk a little bit about your
mentor role models you know whether this
experience sure and so so I had to I had
co-mentors for my PhD releasable for
came harder and Craig flick and and two
different institutions I did my formal
defensive man maker but I also worked a
bathroom in university which is a
smaller very good um school with an
excellent program in biology and and
boldly and happily and let me do my own
thing
chart my own course and that's something
that worked out really well for me so
they let me it gave me the independence
that that personally from abroad food
well and and they also were very
supportive of me subsequently going to
the Salk Institute and Wiley and I mean
I can't say enough great things about
Wiley Wiley like Lydia like it was a
phenomenal mentor and very hands-off and
he really enabled you to take projects
and design them and run with them and
and always there in the background
always available when you have questions
or needed some guidance but but other
than that it was yours to take and run
and do good things with and that was a
wonderful of violence I believe that
learnt a journalism option that's away
and so yeah it's that's those are the
folks who coach to coach me and who I
look up to and who I try to emulate and
how I leave my room today okay and I
know you are busy with your research and
all but just tell us about the
other hobbies you can only you do
anything else other than that he says
sure and I try to make time to to
actually get out of the lab I mean when
we used to be a SoCal nobody North Cal
both are wonderful for the outdoors so
like to hike go on walks and try to do
some trail running every once in a while
and I used to play volleyball and a
little bit less Big Show go on babies
than it used to be in San Diego so and
again we try and spend time outdoors
it's okay and tell us about the other
lab lab people died student post arts
sure so I have four grad students
currently and a post-op and a staff
scientist and a technician and and
that's a good size group and the lab
right now is I get a little heavy on
grad students some us labs are having on
heavy run postdocs and the environment
that I grew up in scientifically back in
the Netherlands the labs that are very
much fun by my classes and so it's an
environment that I'm familiar with and
and and it's working well and we have a
large number of undergraduates well
you're a fantastic bull run graduates at
UC Davis and and we have a number of
them participate in the research help
out and that's actually tremendous fun
because you get to teach them really
really ominously and inspire them
hopefully you like to go out and at
least appreciate the importance of what
we do and how do you motivate them I
know like Democrats have motivation like
sometimes index but men don't work they
really feel bad and all those things are
you pull them back sure um what I'm
trying for what I try to do for each one
of them is to give them and projects
that I think are exciting and get them
started or something that already is to
the point that it's but only to
something that will interest a
successful project with with a
reasonable amount of certainty and I
usually advise them to to not put all
their eggs in one basket so so have at
least
have at least two projects one of them
can be riskier but if one of them
doesn't work out or better some setbacks
you can always turn to and get your
motivation from the other project and I
think so far I mean that's me for that
big so far the circle table not there
and how often you interact like Oh like
is there any policy like oh you yeah
open-door policy
how do you well I think yeah I always
tell them you can you can e-mail or you
can come in every time you can you know
whenever you have questions and I'll let
you know if there is an object if the
moment is not appropriate for you -
really busy but that's fair
so I probably talk to you what is one of
them on a daily basis and we have a more
formal meeting of quantity and so you
had implicating valuable factors and all
those things are how you really focused
on that with info but maybe that going
back back that's kind of a coincidence
oh so as it was sorry my postdoc in
Weyers lab so why leave L discovered
quarterback open dilution factor which
is the main hypothalamic hormone that
case parties and the endocrine stress
response at least a hepatitis pituitary
adrenal axis and and and he not only
discovered the register if he also
discovered three additional peptides the
receptors for all those so he really
charted the whole family over the course
of and a 30-year span and by the time I
joined his lab we had they had
identified all four of those peptides
one of them being a type that I still
saw that heavily which is recorded three
and and it just so happened that your
quotient 3 is opponent being expressed
in beta cells in the pancreas though we
really kind of followed the peptides and
and try and cipher the biology and that
is controlling I thought so that's how
we how we got our start in and in
diabetes research and I'm forever
grateful to the Juvenile Diabetes
Research Foundation because they were
the ones who recognized this early on
and were able to support us to the put
and embarked on on this on the line of
research challenges that I still won
today yeah so God is not about you at a
yellow card entry work from your
presentation to the boy okay
see period all right so I decided to
share two stories today and they both
have to do with Europe ardently and they
both have to do with local crosstalk and
how local crosstalk control beta-cell
faint and function I'm going to talk to
you talking to both of these stories so
just one slide background on the on the
on the why I am interested in in
pancreas and diabetes and we have as
most you will know two major forms of
diabetes type 1 and type 2 which are
really practiced in diseases
type 1 is the autoimmune disease that
destroys insulin-producing beta cos in
the pancreas and almost 200,000
Americans on the under the age of 20
have type 1 and when by the time this
year is over nearly 16,000 children will
have been newly diagnosed in the US
alone and their prevalence of people
type 1 is increasing for reasons that we
don't entirely understand and average
age of diagnosis is between 10 and 12
years of age and that's a little bit
different for type 2 diabetes and this
is the disease often associated with
with lifestyle choices but with a
distinct genetic component or this world
where patients have a relative insulin
deficiency and that is precipitated by
peripheral insulin resistance beta cells
try and compensate are able to do so for
some time at some point that
compensation fails and diabetes and sues
and latest estimates from the CDC or
that over 29 million Americans have type
2 diabetes although not all of them are
aware that they have this disease and
over 1 in 3 Americans has pre-diabetes
and this is a major and health
healthcare and crisis in the making
because it there is a good chance that
those 1 in 3 Americans will develop type
2 diabetes in the in the near future
and and some of the common complications
that are complications for both
uncontrolled and bonnethead to our metro
and microvascular implications increased
attack chance of heart attack and stroke
as well as microvascular implications
which precipitate in kidney disease the
need to amputate lower limbs
chances to go blind for different
payments and together these really still
cause a reduced quality of life and
reduce life expectancy so um most people
who study diabetes ever studied pancreas
are interested in beta cells because
beta cells are the only source of
insulin in our body and whenever beta
cells secrete insulin is leads to a
reduction in blood sugar and I'm also
interested in what else happens in the
islets and bile is do not consist only
of beta cells they're also alpha cells
which make another hormone that's called
glucagon and googan is the opposite and
it has the opposite role of insulin what
insulin tells you about it it stores
nutrients away for later use we've done
talks to the liver and and causes an
increase in blood sugar and to prevent
very low hypoglycemia then there's a
third cell type and a third cell type is
the cell type that and I studied quite
heavily because it is where the biology
is let me and then cell is called the
Delta cell and Delta cell makes another
setting and somatostatin whatever you'll
find that in the body is an excellent
break even hits its target cells in this
case it emits both insulin release from
beta cells and glucagon secretion from
alpha cells and we had known this since
that since the seventies pretty much
says notice that the most discovered but
it had never been fully appreciated how
Delta cells are activated and what we
discovered is that a a the cell peptide
recordin 3 is co released with insulin
and every time I made a subsequent
insulin to act on peripheral insulin
sensitive tissues they also simply some
goo recorded 3 which then activates
Delta cells and Delta cells there is
formed with an increase in somatostatin
to bring the whole thing back down so
the research interest of my lab are this
cluster but also as you lay the beta
cells not all betas are equal
and what does that mean and and this
story has led us to appreciate that that
is really quite a bit of participe
initial identity of islet cells and I'll
talk about this in the second half of
night and on today so um the two stories
I will share with you is how on the one
hand you 0.3 is an eye
that hormone it promotes negative
feedback from Delta cells within the
eyelid response primarily to Europe code
3 coming from beta cells but it also is
responding to other hormones for example
ghrelin Brown had no had long been known
to inhibit insulin secretion but the
mechanism had not been figured out it
turns out that the way the brain is able
to inhibit insulin secretion is by
activating Delta cells Delta cell go on
to inhibit the beta cell and curb
anticipation and in the second half of
what we study that has to do with the
beverage recording 3 in addition to to
controlling local feedback is an
excellent maturation mark of the beta
cells it turns out that beta cells once
they special report three are really
functional beta cells so you record 3
happens to be a wonderful proxy to
determine whether beta cells a function
mature and I'll talk about this at some
length as well so when we started
looking at your importantly and to try
and appreciate its function we we've
done a couple of exercises in this case
what I'm showing you is a dot plot of
basically all messages all hormones and
cytokines encoded by genes in the mouse
eyelid and I ran them by abundance on a
log scale and I've also made install
proportional to its abundance so of
course if you do this for the entire
eyelid insulin and mice happen to have
to insulin genes insulin is the most
abundant soluble factor followed by
amylin and glucagon and really I think
in this ended in this in the sense that
we've gone and a melon and insulin are
the only ones released into circulation
but to act at distal sites this is
really where we draw the line and what
is what our classical hormones and which
would be just these three and which ones
are local factors that in some paradigm
mechanism modulates
the activity of beta cells and alpha
cells and this local role is true for
both soon Ida Stanton and Europe code 3
if you think about it
looking at this graph after incident and
ambulant who look warden 3 the third
most abundant signal coming from the
beta cell and we had no idea what I was
doing you can do this by gene expression
here show
you can also blind eyelids of the
movement and arrive at a very similar
and relative abundance of the three
major of the four major hormones that
I'll be talking about and this is in
this is a quick plot showing that as we
all know as soon as you promote insulin
secretion by going from low to high
glucose and you also Co stimulate and
Elizabeth courtly and if you look at and
how your quadrille insulin are
distributed in the beta cell this is
some super resolution microscopy you can
actually see pretty nicely that both
insulin in red and unicorn 3 and in
green co-localize nicely in yellow in
the secretary granules of beta cells so
we had we knew pretty well where the
signal came from but it was really
struggle to find out what the target was
for and for u13 we know it activates a
Class B GPCR called CHR - we did not
know where what cell type is the main
site of the expression of CH a - and
there's really no that I learned what is
for them so it took us about six years
to get an answer to this question it
required me making a beta cell reporter
line that males or beta cells and red
and crossing this to either an SSD for
glucagon free to lit to lynnea's level
all Delta or alpha cells and once I had
these mice in place I put facts purified
beta cells and either delta or alpha
cells and with this in hand we now have
really nice transcriptomes
for each of these cell types so now we
can really ask the question for energy
and were interested in what cell type or
cell types are the size of expression
and if we do this for a panel of GPCRs
we discover that CH or to the receptor
for your court date is selectively
expressed by Delta cells and by the way
these data are probably available we
host them in this format on their
website so we need to make these graphs
and these browser puffs for yourself
we have two duels and be able to type in
your keyboard right for another line of
evidence that we had and
that pointed us to Delta cells is when
we look like do record three naka islets
these nice are really quite normal
they have only a fairly masculine type
but among the genes that are selectively
repressed in look from the knockout
eyelets all somatostatin HX which is
your transcription factor attachment
show to be high fidelity lineage
commission and retinol binding protein
for which also expressed by Delta salt
and also when we looked at Delta sub
content access the content is down in
Europe only no islands but insulin and
Rubicon content is not so all
indications are that these you quandary
naka islets have a subtle defect only in
Delta cells so we looked at Sonata
setting secretion and insulin secretion
we look at insulin secretion and when we
look at Europe point three no islets we
go from low glucose to high glucose we
see very characteristic spike which is
called the first phase and insulin
secretion which is then followed by a
sustained second phase and as is
evidence evident from this from this
figure the first and second phase
insulin secretion in Europe corn three
knockout mice is exaggerated now as soon
as you lose story recording three by
adding exogenously thirty gurupada
peptide we can rescue this
hypersecretion of insulin so what's
happening here is we're reapplying SSD
secretion but reactivating SSD secretion
and this then inhibited solution brings
a backup model we were very excited when
we found this because a couple years
prior and have been published at this
somatostatin knockout mice has a very
similar view of that in the absence of
somatostatin insulin secretion from SSD
no eyeless is is excessive is
exaggerated both influence and second
phase and as soon as you restore
synthetic SSD that type you can rescue
this feeling that as well
so the fact that the loss of your point
three phenyl copies the loss of SSD so
nicely places them in same feedback loop
so this is all not a mouse this is all
based on upper eyelid so what about
healthy wild-type eyelids so this is an
experiments where we go investigate
adjust that and this is simply looking
at some melatonin secretion from healthy
mouse
mouths silence and I'll talk you through
this figure basically as we go from low
glucose to high glucose we see a
significant increase in SSD situation
this has been now when we add additional
you reporting three we can potentiate
this depletion when we come back with an
antagonist EU recording three with which
is a peptide of a stress intermediate
blocks but doesn't activate the receptor
we can block the effect that your
opponent lee but to our excited
excitement what we also discovered as we
applied is interesting to be by itself
is we can fully block the glucose
stimulated and SSP secretion so this
demonstrated that not just unicorn 3 can
activate Delta cells
this shows that endogenous reportedly is
required for the glucose stimulated
secretion of Samantha set we can do the
same thing in profusion here I'm looking
first at somatostatin secretion as you
go from basal glucose high glucose you
see a market increase in SSD solution
and as soon as we add a stress into V
thereby blocking and dodging is
recording 3 you start to inhibit SSD
secretion and consequently as you look
at insulin secretion as we're starting
to inhibit the negative impact we allow
the deal oppression of insulin so by
inhibiting the feedback that a mediated
by you 243 we can actually cause the
data cells to secrete more insult these
data show that in human islets Sydney
happens we see both on the basal and
high glucose the jewnicorn 3 can
stimulate human assistance whether
second secretion and a special to be
able to significantly Baathist so this
is not an effect that is you need to
Mouse it also happens that so
mechanistically then what is it Lila's
so if we first review how beta cells
responsible goes beta cells in green
they take up glucose to glucose to
glucose transporters analysis to this
glucose gets impaired like gets
metabolized lipolysis TCA cycle
oxidative phosphorylation the leads to
an increase in ATP ATP then acts at 8 ka
t details closes them and triggers
depolarization and which is from
then leads to the opening of l-type
calcium channels calcium flows in and
triggers excessive doses of insulin and
this can be potentiated the loop of
hormones such as glp-1 glucagon-like
peptide 1 which mediates and an increase
in cyclic AMP II through a Class B
g-protein couple receptors this is how
common drugs in diabetes like vertebra
now what we think is that Delta cells
mechanistically and work very similar in
response to your recording so as we
review what happens as we as we
intervene in these key and keep points
in this pathway as we go from low to
high glucose we see a very nice
secretion of insulin and as we either
force the KDP channels in the open
conformation preventing their closure we
can fully block insulin secretion as we
block l-type calcium channels we can do
the same thing so this demonstrates as
you've been well known that both KDP
channels and l-type calcium channels are
required for insulin solution now when
we apply these same drugs and look at
SST series you see that both of these
drugs also are able to inhibit unko
stimulated SSD secretion but what we did
not know at the time is whether this is
because of the direct effects of delta
cells or whether this repression was
mediated by the inhibition of your
important release from beta cells so we
then went back and apply a synthetic duo
currently and if you apply synthetic
group colon 3 you can potentiate you can
stimulate SSD solution which then
predictably leads to it repression of
insulin secretion so now the question
was well what happens if you apply those
oxide and Israeli pain in the presence
of that needle point 3 can you
importantly overcome the inhibition by
diazoxide an Israeli beam and the answer
is no so um this means that you need
both ATP channels and l-type calcium
channels at the level of the Bell de sel
in addition to the potentiated signal
from middle court 3 so what this then
showed us is that mechanistically the
Delta cell and the beta cell respond
very similarly they both respond to
glucose and the ATP that is generated by
glucose metabolism and they both require
ATP channels and alpha calcium channels
and to allow
the extra dose of their payload SST and
in the case of Delta cells insulin
invasive beta cells and in north cell
types that is the possibility to
potentiate secretion by a peptide GPC I
needed immediate amplification back
alright so we wanted to take this
envelope and intervene in endogenous
your cotton 3 signaling so in order to
do this we generated a reporter or a
mouse that allowed us to over express
your point 3 specifically in beta cells
so this is a classic doctor such an
inducible mouse model where we have a
beta cell specific driver of the first
epicyclic rat activator protein within
which they can activate the expression
of a and of a unicorn 3 transgene under
control of a doctor sacra active
promoter
activatable promoter so ensure you need
to have you need to make three
Commission's for amounts to start to
over a special recording 3 specifically
in beta cells you need to K both of
these transgenes
and you need to administer administer
dr. cipher so when we've done that and
so these are the eyelids from 8
individual mice and only the mouse that
has both of the required transgenes
and has SUSE doxycycline will respond
with a nice increase in transgenic girl
court age question and this is important
this miss transgenics importantly
expression is at the same order of
magnitude as endogenous also 2 for 3 so
we're not over expressing by a wild
margin we're really hitting an
appropriate dose that is on par with the
endogenous that was in report three and
we're effectively doubling total report
three levels in this class so with this
massive hand we went back and asked some
questions in biology and the first
question that we asked is is what
happens if you start to express report 3
earlier than normal and something that
I'll talk about in a little bit more
detail later on is we had known module
point 3 and post label there too so
after birth isn't really get expressed
in in most beta cells it takes until
about 3 weeks after birth before all
beta cells or at least a large majority
of them it co-expressed you record 3
insulin and we
publishes and then Barak bloom when he
was still without notice that made a
very interesting scenes and observations
he showed that and this onset of you
recording the expression correlates with
some really interesting changes in the
beta cell threshold for glucose so and
if you look at P 15 Islands which are
equivalent in their response to how and
adult islets will respond if you if you
take these islets and you take their
glucose levels from point five million
molar which is hypoglycemic to 2.8
million molar and typically we'll see no
response and as you take them from two
point eight or quantify it back to
sixteen point eight you get is very nice
first phase the second phase secretion
that have also shown now if you did the
exact same trace on postnatal one an
island suppose on the one pups you see a
very different pattern now as you go
from point five to two point eight glory
see if you lose face and second phase
and again you see a similar response at
sickbed 16.7 millimolar glucose
so the these islets these beta cells are
more sensitive to glucose and this
translates into a higher level of
insulin and consequently a lower level
of blood glucose it this this type of
behavior has been known for some time
but what Barak was able to do is he was
able to correlate and these this
phenomenon with the onset of 0.8 now
we've taken it one step further based on
on these observations and we use these
dr. ii in Tuzla mice so then prematurely
induce unicorn 3 so we gave you record
32 pregnant dams and that themselves
were in pimple of over expressing the
recording 3 and we we basically were
able to only invite transgenic pups
greatly over express the levels of your
0.38 personal data and when we look at
the plasma glucose levels of these mice
and and this was done blind because we
had no idea at the time of this
experiment which of the cubs were key by
transgenic one said which ones with the
controls but when we do this and we we
personality the by transgenic and dogs
induced mice because we can very nicely
see that the wild-type or the control
mice and took about three weeks of age
to mature that bottle cause levels to
the normal levels that we see in mice
and but these by transgenic dog seduced
by it's the ones will be prematurely
into 0.3 their plasma glucose values
make sure much sooner and what's
happening here is we are prematurely
activating Delta so they're connected
back but prematurely inhibiting insulin
secretion and this prematurely allows
and plasma glucose to rise to levels
that we typically see only in young
adult or adult mice as soon as
endogenous Europe currently comes on
it's over expressing a little bit more
doesn't really make a difference in okay
so so this test that summarize say what
we normally see in the early postnatal
time period but we have no 0.3 plasma
glucose especially determined by the
balance of insulin action and different
action and as soon as you record lead
comes on and this activates negative
feedback and this antagonists insulin
action so this then what is responsible
for the increase in plasma glucose
levels to the levels that we typically
associate with non fasting plasma
glucose levels in us alright so we then
went to a disease model we looked at
elBulli mice and all we all be mice and
which are minus the leptin deficient
they are morbidly obese and they develop
severe diabetes and they also lose the
impression of unicorn through early on
and we knew this so what we did in an
instant translates into a lack of SST
secretion that is really hardly any SST
coming from these islets under any
circumstance meaning that the negative
feedback control in these islands is
pretty much all but gone and we'll talk
about what that might mean and but what
we did is we took our dog cycle induce
for mouse and model we bred it onto the
opioid background and we followed these
mice for about six and a half weeks at
six and half weeks we know that you're
forty three levels are mostly gone so at
this point in time we place them on top
speed and so we restore the expression
if you importantly and from the moment
we did this we saw this markers increase
in plasma glucose levels which is
independent of body weight which is
unaffected by any of this intervention
so what's happening here again
we restore your opponent Lee will
restore Delta so dependent inhibitory
feedback on beta cells we probably
inhibit insulin secretion which then
causes plasma glucose levels to actually
go up a little bit so by restoring this
feedback we actually exacerbate diabetes
so why have this feeling mechanism well
this is something that we wondered and
the way we think about this and is that
this is a nice way to restore that
restore or to counteract I progressed
emia and diabetes by shutting down
negative feedback but normally like many
things in biology you need proper
negative feedback control to to have
tight control over your parameter and
glucose is obviously no difference so to
visualize that what we did is we
outfitted mice with continuous glucose
monitors and and mouse to see walk
around here here is one of the monitors
on its back this is a continuous glucose
monitor that is used by people with type
1 diabetes it sends a signal every five
minutes to this handheld receiver which
normally isn't placed in the home page
but eat it so just for the purpose of
this video and this allows us to monitor
glucose and free movement animals over
time and when we did this to both to
lean mice over the course of 72 hours
and we can see this very nice and tight
control of a blood glucose there's small
incursions but this is testament to how
well healthy pancreas works now when we
did the same thing to OB OB morbidly
obese and littermates and we saw that
the average glucose were much higher
this is no surprise we noticed but what
was surprising to us and is the degree
of volatility in these glucose profiles
of all really nice and to us what this
means is you no longer have the ability
to timely
attenuate insulin secretion leading to
an overshoot of insulin which then needs
to be compensated so so by losing that
local feedback you lose tight control or
when to activate but also when to shut
down the beta cell and it's insulin
switch so I think in a healthy
individual this local feedback is really
important to ensure that you have tight
control of insulin solution and
therefore
Google's alright so is it does any of
this hold in humans and the answer is
yes so we we looked at a cohort of human
anchors donors that we'll take from
people at the end or consortium and and
in humans there is little species
difference where you look on Three's
Express also by alpha cells so what
we've done is we stained human donors we
applied masks to define beta and alpha
cells and then we were able to isolate
the intensity of the Europe or three
span in beta cells and in alpha cells
and what you can see hopefully in this
particular set of examples is that um in
a human type 2 diabetes donor and beta
cells are reduced by the incident the
unicorn 3 intensity in these beta cells
is also reduced compared to the
situation in a healthy dog whereas the
intensity in alpha cells is far less
affected now human patients being human
patients and being individual and
therefore suffering from variation we
also were fortunate enough to
collaborate with Lily pound and Kevin
Grove and tell most OHSU and they had
this wonderful cord of macaque macaques
that they had had on either low low fat
diet on a high-fat diet for launch
number uh for a number of of years and
been shredded beef samples with us
something to be exact same thing there
we stained a macaque iris for you at
point three we parsed out the intensity
recording data cells and alpha cells and
we compare them between the control
cohort and low fat diet and - guy effect
macaques that either turn out to be
sensitive to insulin so resistant to
diet or sensitive to the diet and offer
developments and resistant so he's a
pretty diabetic I haven't they haven't
progressed to Frank diabetes and already
we start to see you up on three and a
signal taper off
specifically in beta cells and be
unaffected in alpha cells so so unicorn
3 is lost really early on probably in
pre-diabetes and both in humans and
particularly also in the tax so so this
feedback control that we discovered is
not
relevant for for loader models it also
comparable not in a human disease
so the someone is this part the point I
want to make here and that is been
ignored I think a little bit is it Delta
cells are really important so some I
often get asked well our Delta cells how
can our only so fuels and how can they
ever be and meaning meaningfully
contributing to how insulin and glucagon
are secreted and I shown a video like
this where you see all beta cells in red
and Delta cells really a large number of
them and then enveloping the whole core
of beta cells and and I think this
there's ample evidence to suggest that
there is enough Delta cells and all we
have to do is secrete an oscillator
setting to the fact their immediate
neighbors and and and control the
behavior of those cells so we think that
feedback from the other cells we've
shown it's triggered by you recording 3
and it determines the set point for
plasma glucose during post endo
maturation and it timele attenuates
insulin release to prevent insulin
secretion from overshooting which then
would need to be compensated by a
compensatory release glucagon so this is
an example where local feedback between
two neighboring cells is important group
determined physiological parameter I've
also shown you that this intro eyelid
Delta so dependent local feedback breaks
down early in diabetes it may on the one
hand be a compensatory mechanism to
allow maximum insulin secretion in the
face of insulin resistance but also it
contributes it back to its
pathophysiology because it helps explain
how tight control over glucose breaks
down and debuts and I think the other
cells are not only important to to
explain the acetabular point 3 I think
the other cells really serve as this
local control hub that integrates
signals from a variety of different
sources not only Europe on three life
examples of Berlin and can translate
this into tonic inhibition on on insulin
sedation from beta sauce okay so the
second half of the story I was going to
share today it has to do with the
property that euro coin 3 is is really
wonderful maturity marketing beta cells
and this particular picture shows
posting all day to where
a good number of beta cells already
Express is reported three but quite a
few of them indicated by arrows do not
and and and we've for a while thought
that by the time that my situation rolls
around and obey this is especially
record pretty well turns out that that's
not entirely the case let's assess
allele at all it'll share in the next
couple of slides so a little bit of
background it's been long thought that
maintenance and regeneration of beta so
mass is controlled exclusively by slowed
beta cell self renewal and it always is
contribute to this process and and this
is filling the main mechanism at which
beta cell mass can be restored or
expanded at least in large models and
but the problem is that human there is a
proliferation at best is a slow process
and the disease where this is most
relevant type one diabetes and by the
time that somebody presents at their
doctor they're usually already and and
at a point in their disease when it lost
corners with a beta cells to ongoing an
autumn in the salt so and then patients
are placed on insulin treatment but to
come back from a situation where you
have few with any beta cells left that
are still ongoing or experiencing
autoimmune attack and knowing the beta
cells at best proliferate slowly this is
not a particularly appealing target to
try and restore beta so handsome patient
with type one diabetes so then a couple
of really interesting studies came
around that then I think captivated the
attention of the field and by Pedro
Rivera who showed that if you completely
play beta cells you can you can cause or
or activate considered more plasticity
islet cell fate he showed in they showed
in a couple of papers that both alpha
and delta cells under the right
circumstances can transition to beta
cells so the story i will show is is
that we think that that is actually a
presence of a population of beta cells
that we call virgin beta cells that
arises via trans differentiation from
non beta cell progenitors and especially
to find niche and that occurs at the
edge of islets of healthy pancreatitis
so we think that this participe is not
just limited to two models or
of beta cell loss and thankfully injury
but we think this is a normal part that
happens that a normal part of
maintenance of beta cell master edits on
us and and what led us to this to this
conclusion is the following and set of
observations this is an image of a mouse
island where I think you'll agree with
me that most beta cells would equal that
all equally salient and silly for
insulin then you see this nice
peripheral rim of alpha cells labels for
glucagon now if we start to overlay
unicorn 3 labeling and you start to see
significant heterogeneity not all beta
cells are equally green and if you look
carefully there's actually a couple of
beta cells that are clearly red but if
you take away total off the red signal
there is no green on the underlying that
red so these beta cells are not
expressing you report 3 at all so the
one thing that we also observed about
these is that these cells tend to occur
at the edge of the eyelid and we wanted
to quantify that so we do that we
designed an algorithm that really
basically and defines both the outlined
in the center-of-mass for every item and
automatically detects the at the
location of inch nucleus in these islets
and we can then use this to map the
position of every cell in this eyelid
automatically across hundreds of islets
and thousands of cells and in order and
the way we do this is we assign a value
to every dot and if a value a cell
nucleus that is close to the center of
the eyelid will be assigned a low value
so we draw a line from the center from
the center of the eyelid through that
cell to the to the edge to the to the
nearest edge and when a eyelid when a
cell is close to the edge we will assign
it a high value close to one when an
islet cell is close to the center it
will be assigned a value closer to zero
and we can then use this to distribute
to plot the distribution remove the
distribution of every cell in the eyelid
and that current holes look like this
for the simple factor that is more and
space more real estate at the periphery
of the eyelid for cells to
to sit there and there's very few cells
that are sit in the very center of edit
and for obvious reasons and if we then
start to break down all these cells into
their cell types we can see that mature
beta cells tend to distribute slightly
more central than the average cell and
alpha cells tend to distribute in mice
at least and very peripheral which is a
recapitulation of the non architecture
of Mouse islets so this in a way
validates our approach and now we did
the same thing for these immature cells
and we've done this over I think there
were 23 animals in this particular study
and hundreds of immature beta cells and
very clearly as you do this these
immature beta cells as a population tend
to distribute quite faithfully just in
internal from the lair of alpha cells
but but markedly more peripheral than
the average beta cell and as you
quantify this what we are left with is
it all these postnatal development a
large proportion of beta cells that is
reportedly negative but these cells
persist and they they persist at about 1
to 1.5 percent of all beta cells so I've
shown you previously that in diabetes
beta cells lose recording 3 so the
question then became well are these beta
cells beta cells that have been
differentiated are they diseased or
dysfunctional beta cells all are these
beta cells that have never before
expressed your cornea and for immature
little mini is facing which you can do a
nice to address this question and when
we use a Europe currently free line to
drive the edge question of in this case
membrane GFP is a vinius water we can
see a peripheral beta cells which are
labeled for insulin which are red this
is the NCM gene also a linear negative
cell will be red and the newest possible
will be green and we can see that these
bed is at the edge our Linnaeus negative
for your point 3 which indicates that
they've never before been a mature beta
cell so this is how we know that these
cells have have arrived from a non beta
progenitor that has never before been
immature basal so we also have a
wonderful by presented mouse lined up
with the thoughts at our disposal to
really isolate these cells and visualize
them and
is a combination of a nuclear sharing
driven by the incident one promoter
which I was all the other cells within
bread that we cross to a Europe or a GFP
reporter whose levels all mature beta
cells agree and as you do as you
visualize it a little you can buy these
pockets of immature cells at either
periphery and as you open up the 3d and
the 3d islets disease tanks you can see
these pockets of immature cells at
periphery but the entire core that is
uniformly labeled from your country and
then cherry so these are all immature
beta cells so using this particular by
transgenic mice we can then do a former
facts based purification or we can
isolate the N cherry single positive
immature beta cells and GFP and cherry
co+ mature beta cells and get that
transcriptomes and when you do this you
find that the image of beta cells even a
bit different from matures they still
must together and separate from all the
non beta and defense cells and these
islets so these images beta cells are
more beta than anything else but they're
also distinct from mature beta cells and
for example they have reduced expression
of your pollen 3 which is the marker
that color settlements on this on this
path they also have reduced expression
of mana fame and increased expression of
mapping in these two transcription
factors are known to be markers for
mature beta cells in the case of FB MFA
and they're known to be expressed in
immature cells in case of Matt be so
this cracks exactly with what you will
expect for immature beta cells and when
you new pathway analysis you can find
this this is a schematic representation
of the beta cell you can see that
basically every single pathway that we
know beta cells need to engage in
glucose sensing leading to insulin
secretion are down regulated in immature
beta cells these are genes involved in
the TCA cycle genes involved in
oxidative phosphorylation they are all
met all almost always significantly down
regulated in the image of beta cells
compared to the mature beta cells and we
can validate some of these also by you
know fluorescence for example there is
an immature beta cell here and periphery
which is very low and especially for g6p
c2 which is required for seventh and the
glucose special for the beta cells
and this is also a cell that is not has
no your quadri we've also got this for
you one light be a number of different
markers so so the transcriptional
changes that we show a whole of very
well as we do validation by antibody
based ones but everything is down in
these beta cells those ruble cells group
of genes that is known as this allow
genes it is by Rutter and from Scott and
Anil Bhushan move forward in these
concepts these are genes that are known
to be expressed by maturing by immature
beta cells or beta so to development
that needs to be that repressed as beta
cells mature into a functional aerosol
so you will expect these genes to be
high or enrich to energy beta cells and
again that's exactly what we see
and then finally you've done some of
that physiology while you forced what we
depolarize these cells and look at
calcium currents and whereas mature beta
cells respond to a force depolarization
with an influx of calcium which is what
they need to engage in insulin secretion
immature beta cells appear to be
incapable of multi calcium influx so
they would be functionally aching both
responding even if they were able to
sense glucose and but we think they
cannot so this is another example where
we validated our mRNA expression I RNA
seek with antibody based detection of
cell service gluten and these peripheral
insulin positive or negative beta cells
which are highlighted by these arrows
they have and and they have no cell
surface bluetooth so they're they're
read or do not reason they also back
there and their cell surface little
which is white and so if these cells
have no glue to and cannot sense moko as
well can they take up glucose so we've
actually set this up and what I'm going
to show you is a video where I'm going
to apply a glucose trace in green and
what you can see over time is that as
soon as we apply the glucose trace it
progressively permeates the entire
eyelid and sends individual cells and
really throughout the beta cell mass and
again beta cells in this case are
indicated by a red nucleus with the
exception of a handful of peripheral
cells which are red and red nucleus the
beta cells and every donor
of any and it glucose and that's best
summarized here where if you quantify
incident I'm sorry as you play if you
quantified Lucas update you see and a
significantly repressed through but I've
taken imager beta cells contacted each
advances and again as we look at human
islets you can also find evidence for
these cells that we have no better feel
idiots trace but what we have done is
we've looked at really young male mates
human donors where we can find clusters
of cells that are insulin positive but
you record through negative and
interestingly these tend to occur at the
interface of areas with alpha cells and
areas of beta cells so again suggesting
if it is something special to the area
within the eyelid where different to
open it so if you cells are coming from
a non beta cell source what is that
source and since these cells occur in
close proximity to alpha cells the
obvious question also given the fact
that everywhere I show that alpha
certification can take place do these
cells arrive from alpha cells so we've
done the experiment where we lineage
label all alpha cells in this case in
green and then we've labeled with the
combination of glucagon for alpha cells
and your according three four mature
beta cells and we can find cells such as
the pair of cells in this particular
detail where and we have a pair of cells
that clearly is green so used to be
alpha cells but they've lost the
expression of glucagon and instead they
now Express group 0.3 so they've gone
from a alpha cell faith to obey the
sulfate so we used a book run free that
is not a dutiful so the concern
obviously is that this could either be a
stochastic artifact of the line and
where we just randomly label a low
frequency of beta cells if that would be
the case we would find we would expect
to find random basis across key so the
source of the eyelid to be labeled for
Linnaeus labels felucca it could also be
that during development there is a stage
where a progenitor cell is transiently
co+ or is going to move on before it
goes on comes beta cell
in the process picks up an alpha cell
lilies little if that were the case as
beta cell as islands are formed by
expansion beta so mass one would expect
to find clusters of projectiles labeled
beta cells and at random locations in
islets and we do not you know we do not
observe this at all
instead what we observe is that we see
these minis label and beta cells the
beta cells that have an album some image
they will occur only at the periphery of
the islets and we can quantify this by
using the exact same distribution trick
that we developed earlier and if we do
this we can very clearly see the vision
these beta cells with an alpha subunit
they will occur highly selectively edge
of the iron again just internal from the
Alpha soap and mantle and just to show
you how this fits in with these immature
Baker cells that I that I've started
with and we think that these immature
beta cells that Express insulin but not
yet Europe currently are a transitionary
stage and that is on its way to becoming
an ASL and that there is a couple of
examples here in this case two different
cells that both are linear is positive
for alpha cells in this case that green
the bottom cell already is positive for
both insulin and you report three so
it's completed its transition from an
alpha to beta cell but the top cell is
positive for insulin but negative for
your point three so this is an example
of an immature beta cell that is coming
from an alpha cell at faith so it's in
in unruly people from alpha to beta
cells has lost moving on it is a quiet
insulin but it has not yet acquired your
quote
alright so we can also isolate these
cells this is a strategy of requires
three different trends genes again are
them Mouse insulin and cherry reporter
labeling all beta cells in bed and then
accommodation of gluten-free and yfp the
Linnaeus label or beta cells you can see
these clusters of cells at the periphery
I clearly have a red nucleus but are
green so they cannot lose the white P
but as they become beta cells they
acquire a red nucleus so this allows us
to flex purify these cells they're rare
but they exist and we can get enough of
them to get transcriptomes and as we
look at the transcript under these
differentiated cells they
more similar to beta cells than they are
to the Albus elevated once for though by
all indications these cells look like
they ourselves they've lost will be gone
they require insulin angular for three
but the big question was um do these
beta cells Albus origin actually behave
like a normal beta cell so they look
like beta cells and all the right
markers but what is the functional
behavior so we tested this and we did
this by using calcium indicator for G
chem stick the needs Christy ten six in
a Cree dependent manner and in alpha
cells and which light before is a
Linnaeus level but at the same time
allowed us to the nanotubes to the SS T
and the behavior of these cells in
intact islets over time so we're
combining these two properties of this
particular phlox Turville so what I'm
going to show you here is before we go
into the trusty frustrating part is a
movie where I'm going to indicate
illustrate the prototypical behavior of
alpha cells and beta cells so on the
Left you're going to see an island where
all bases are labeled in red I know al I
know alpha cells are Linnaeus level for
G cap six so as the time course starts
and we'll apply a VP which is a peptide
that no that is known to act activate
alpha cells and every time we apply a
puff of ATP we see Alex uh sprinkle
individually there's no coordination
amongst them they each respond to their
own rhythm and then this depolarization
at the end just to show that they are
viable throughout the whole experiment
now I'm going to show you an experiment
with beta cells again all beta cells are
labeled in red and but now we also
express your point G camp in beta cells
and instead of a VPAP we apply blue
coats and we see this very nice
pulsatile and behavior to continuous
glucose which is well known and a
hallmark of healthy beta cell function
but notice how this is much different
from the response of alpha cells so now
that we
had established how beta cells and alpha
cells ought to respond normally again
alpha cells respond to a VP and in a non
coordinated fashion that each respond
individually whereas beta cells have
this very nice pulsatile pattern that is
immediately by gap junction information
and we can we can now start to look for
evidence of functional maturation of
functional transdifferentiation again we
use an insulin and cherry labeling all
beta cells in red and we linear label
the entire Alpha so limits using G chem
sticks so when I play this particular
movie you're going to see a close-up of
a single eyelid where now I'm going to
apply first ATP and then glucose so as
we apply ATP you see individual alpha
cells twinkle just as before so these
are your conventional alpha cells that
respond to ATP now we're switching to
glucose and obviously these different
Google cells that is pulsing to glucose
just like beta cells with that at the
periphery of the islet and they have a
red new place so meaning that they are
currently beta cells because the
expression of entry is contingent on
insulin promoter activity
so as you summarize this particular
video that is to process of cells that
is one close to the cells and that
responds a typical Elvis of fashion to
ATP and and then twinkles and then it
doesn't really respond to glucose and at
the end responds to the polarization and
contrast this to the second cluster of
cells which has no response to ATP
whatsoever they lost all alpha so traits
but they start to break out of this
beautiful pulsatile secretion and in a
response to glucose so these are cells
that then have completed their trans
depreciation of alpha to functionally
mature beta cells so final piece of data
I'll share is that this is not limited
to alpha to beta so transdifferentiation
we think this happens both ways and this
is a particular example but we've
Linnaeus label all beta cells so all
beta cells all mature beta cells are
green and we see examples this is an
example of one image where we do
two cells that no longer Express
frequently so these are cells at once
were mature beta cells at last through
point three and now require to look it
up and and we can actually this is the
final video I'll show you we can
actually also visualize the behavior of
these cells so these are two different
eyelids one of which when one of its
four alpha cells alone is labeled with G
chem 6 and the second is all mature beta
cells have been enabled G chem 6 and
we're going to take these disparate
islets through the same stimulation
protocols before so again and it's two
eyelets and look around
Linnaeus label on the Left mature beta
cell your 2.30 visible on the right and
we're going to first by ATP and this
these two cells on the beta cell eyelid
that respond to ATP they developed
respond to glucose in contrast to all
the other babies in the same island and
then at the very end of the Oviatt they
come back and they respond to KCl so
again there's these two cells here that
as soon as we apply a VP and these two
cells that are lineage they will buy you
2.3 they used to be mature beta cells
they respond to a VP just like the Elvis
of the neighboring Island they do not
respond to glucose unlike all the beta
cells in this particular toilet and they
all respond to KCl based depolarization
so this is an example that again at the
periphery of the mouse islet mature beta
cells trans differentiate into alpha
cells so this is not a one-way street we
think there is this constant exchange in
sulfate taking place at the periphery of
the header so this summarizes it's it's
still true that cell replication is the
main mechanism of beta cell mass matrix
and listen nice but this is not
particularly people targeting in cases
of extreme a this a lot of such as human
type one diabetes so what we've
discovered is the trans differentiation
between alpha and beta cells both ways
takes place at a new genetic a specific
location at the periphery of health
little eyelets and the unicorn 3
negative image
the cells that we discovered we think
are intermediate stage in those
transdifferentiation processes and we
think that this kind invitation is
driven by the complex combination of
signals that converges locally at the
niche and these signals may have nothing
to do with anchors injury or or repair
they may be part of the normal complex
and mixture of signals that could be
neurotransmitters that could be alpha or
beta or Delta's all right and that that
can be found at the end that come
together at the edge of the eyelid and
and we think this is exciting simply
because these cells exist but I think
it's also exciting that we find this
ongoing maturation of beta cells and
healthy islets because this exact
maturation is what's the current
bottleneck in generating beta cells for
stem cells
so what by studying back beta some
iteration and at the periphery of Mouse
islets we can actually learn what
distinguishes our functional immature
beta cell from an immature beta cell and
and this will allow us to just to to
learn how we can turn immature beta
cells or beta cell like cells and make
me the true functional immature beta
cells that are capable of meaningfully
restoring insulin production again
people with type 1 diabetes so with that
I'd like to thank the folks in my group
who've done a ton of this world and
particularly telling Tom and Alex and
Michael contributed to the last story
that I shared and then talita along with
Sidney and Joan Farah and Sophie for
members in my group and who who drove
the story on the prosper and a wonderful
set of collaborators and Michael was
responsible for some of the algorithms
that we generated long-standing
collaboration with Micah and Klaus and
Amanda were generous in supplying the
cochlea our mice that it didn't show
what were instrumental in us making the
case that we see press differentiation
in which in in adult islands and and
then and human pancreas or slides from
the encode consortium live human islets
from the IABP construction and
is funding from the Juvenile Diabetes
Research Foundation and a hard wall
Foundation and with that I thank you for
your attention thank you thanks Marty
it's really nice very wonderful overview
of how the things work with your pardon
the differentiation alpha beta cells out
there I have a couple of questions
because we are almost out of time
regarding your flashback and get me
right is there any specific sense that
for your parking so reading on the data
cells where they had significant on some
other value
sure so the receptor for your record 3
is the C range receptor 2 it's a Class B
g-protein coupled receptor we know that
as far as we know I think they have a
good sense this is the only the center
that is people responding to your point
3 and it is selectively expressed by
only Delta cells and the other question
in the same thing is like you have
mentioned that and yes it is shown the
data that you know [ __ ] goes down
during diabetes and all can it be used
as a pre diabetic marker okay this one
this person might be getting there now
it is basically the triglycerides and
all those things it doesn't I mean like
for example my triglycerides even up for
last names and I'm not diabetic so it
doesn't mean anything so the question is
can this be used as a marker a this is
really like in a couple of years you
might get diabetes but sure kind of
thing I think the particularly McCart
data which are just a wonderful
opportunity for us because there's so
much more control then then wherever
samples we can get from impulse which
which just has more variation to them I
think the lookout that I'll be very
strong with that this is something this
is a protein that is already loaded
before Frank diabetes the missing piece
to think the thing with the master so is
how are we
to measure it systemically and you can
measure it clearly on biopsy samples but
they saw that's not that's not an
appropriate way to diagnose freediving
it and so anything that's like moving I
mean it's it's detectable in blood but
as I indicated I think all of these
signals are any local signals that are
released in high enough quantities to to
reach the neighboring cells either
through the capillaries or three
essential compartments they there enough
of them there to to be released into the
systemic circulation so measuring them
in systemic circulation and the
sensitivity of the measurement is going
to be the bottleneck and whether we're
able to say something or use your
reporting tree as a monitor to indicate
ongoing dysfunctional beta cells and
pre-diabetes and I think it's
potentially possible and I think that's
what we're going to have to make some
improvements if we wanted to go down
that path I mean like that would be I
think that is one of the real like that
with your data and other data it shows
that it goes down hey there is something
wrong with the beta cells and like we
have glucose tolerance test right like
something like that that is some way you
can measure it and show that a time
we're going to say diabetes in few years
that might be a real way to change the
lifestyle or whatever you want to do
okay
but the treatment yes it's very
interesting I'm really appreciate you
coming on and show us your work and I
think everybody would like your balls
and we will put it out on our website
immediately you see eight and on our
homepage in the next couple of days over
and again thanks thank you thank you so
much and I appreciate your time I thank
you very much follow me on IG sure